what the ford motor company describes as
a shock to the electric vehicle market
the company is getting ready to roll out
its all-electric f-150 lightning the
f-series truck has been america's best
selling for decades and a huge profit
center for ford the launch comes as
gasoline prices remain high at near
all-time highs actually and interest in
electric vehicles is on the rise the
f-150 lightning will be the first
mass-market electric pickup in the u.s
and this morning chris van cleave takes
a test drive
the nation's best selling vehicle is
fully charged and about to roll out of
the factory gas free at 580 horsepower
zero to 60 in a little over four seconds
up to 320 miles on a single charge and
starting at 40 grand this
is the electric f-150 lightning i can't
wait to have it dustin koenig came to
the detroit launch event from cleveland
to get a first glimpse of the electric
pickup he's among the nearly 200
thousand to reserve one and like 80
percent of them it'll be his first ev
it's going to be game changing and i
think it's going to show a lot of people
who were skeptics before that you can
have a truck that's electric and be even
better than the old ice dinosaurs
ice or internal combustion engine
vehicles are still driving the car
market but that's slowly changing as gas
prices climbed this year online searches
for evs surged up 60 percent year to
date 55 percent of gas powered car
owners say they are considering going
electric and nearly 160 000 did in the
first quarter of 2022 evs now account
for about 4.6 percent of all registered
vehicles nationwide this is an
incredibly important product for ford
it's the best selling vehicle in the us
and has been for decades now so ford
cannot mess this up tim stevens is
editor-in-chief of cnet cars and spent
last week driving the lightning around
san antonio this is definitely a truck
for people who are doing
everyday truck things i think one of the
most impressive options here is the
ability to power a job site from the
truck the electric f-150 is in fact a
rolling generator designed to power a
job site a tailgate party even an entire
home for three days in the event of a
power failure the f series has been the
best selling truck in the u.s since 1977
and the best selling vehicle for 41
years for decades it's embodied
americans love of big gas guzzling
trucks so taking the f-150 electric was
meant to send a message we're going to
set the tone for the industry
and it's a pivotal point for us linda
zhang is the lightning's chief engineer
i think driving this vehicle really
makes believers it changes hearts and
minds in terms of what
this product can do and it's just as
tough as all of our f series what's not
the same the lightning comes with a
frunk or front trunk where the engine
used to be now can hold up to 400 pounds
and has enough outlets to charge tools
or host an all-electric
front gate party
for cbs saturday morning i'm chris van
cleave in san antonio
i want to know if we're going to start
changing and saying front gate party i
like that i like that and i like the
fact that it's a rolling generator an
entire home can be powered for three
days sold
right there rolling up to times square
trucks yes can't wait to see get out hey
i'm in the market for a new car so hey